STEPHANIE WONG: With almost
500 sessions at Next 2018,
it's understandable that you
couldn't get to them all.
So if you didn't see
Flexible, Easy Data Pipelines
with Cloud Composer,
then stay tuned,
because here's the Rewind.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
If you're a company dealing
with loads of complex data,
then chances are you
deal with a whole set
of computational workflows in
your computing environment.
For example, let's say you
had a lot of on-prem files
that you needed to push
up to Cloud storage.
And each time you
did, you wanted
to load the data into BigQuery
and run an ETL query, which
notifies the Slack
channel when progress
is complete with a link
to the logs from the work.
Now, traditionally,
creating and managing
these types of workflows
on Google Cloud Platform
was a cumbersome
operation that ranged
from easy and inflexible,
like using Cron simple tasks,
to really complex
frameworks that
might require a
team of engineers
to build and get right.
Thankfully, Cloud
Composer has recently
been released to
general availability
to make all of that
a whole lot easier.
At its core, Cloud Composer
is a scalable service
built on the open-source
project Apache Airflow,
meaning that you can still
focus on authoring Airflow
workflows while GCP
makes creating, managing,
and deploying your
workflows much easier.
It works like this.
Cloud Composer
orchestrates your workflow
by using Directed Acyclic
Graphs, or DAGs, which
are the representation of tasks
that Airflow needs to run,
including all of
the relationships
and dependencies involved.
And to facilitate
this orchestration,
composers use Python
to let you dynamically
create powerful pipelines
quickly and collaborate
alongside anyone familiar
with the language.
Of course, running
on Google Cloud
means that your
tasks have access
to the full suite
of Google services,
including access to the
developer console, Cloud
SDK, Identity-Aware Proxy,
Stackdriver, IAM, and more.
But one of the best things is
that Cloud Composer gives you
the ability to
connect your pipeline
through a single orchestration
tool, whether your workflow
lives on premises, in multiple
clouds, or fully within GCP.
The ability to author, schedule,
and monitor your workflows
in a unified manner
means that you
can break down the silos
in your environment
and focus less on
infrastructure.
Now, in the full
talk, the speakers
give a great example
of the core process
of how to use
Composer, including
a live demo of getting a
workflow up and running.
Check out the full talk, linked
in the description below,
and don't forget to subscribe
to the Cloud YouTube
channel for more great
Next Rewind content.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]